what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to Joe Rogan talking about the
rise of single lonely men before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos question for the audience is Joe
Rogan red pill I think he gets more and
more red pill every year all right let's
roll the clip Joe Rogan on 60 oh wait I
forgot guys don't forget don't forget
we're doing meetups in the US and the UK
so if you want to do any of those make
sure you sign up for our Google form the
link to that is in the description okay
right you know
this is It's really scary stuff because
uh I read this uh statistic recently
that said that there's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 30 plus percent of women
are single but it's in the neighborhood
of 60 of men really yeah Stephen King is
fine really high I know in what age
should be really hot it's uh you know 18
to 49 or something oh wow oh that goes
from 18 to 49 I thought it was just
young men remember the exact numbers but
it's young it's a shocking League it
doesn't make sense like why there's such
a disparity between the genders that
meant yeah my question are we dating the
same men or are we dating older oh much
more single than women like that doesn't
even yeah how does that happen like how
sense most men are single most young
women are not
maybe the guys are just saying they're
single and all the girls are like we're
in a relationship it is just a research
right so it's just a Serbia or are the
girls in situationships saying they're
in a relationship what if that's the
actual answer the women are in a talking
phase where the men say they're single
30 percent of U.S adults are neither
married living with a partner nor
engaged in a committed relationship
nearly half of all young adults are
single 34 percent of women in a whopping
63 percent of men
like wow how does that work how does it
work if there's roughly 50 percent women
50 men how could 34 percent of women be
single and 63 percent of them at what
age did he say did you hear it no but
did he say like up to what age all right
go back most men are single most young
women are not maybe the guys are just
saying they're single and all the girls
are like oh see he didn't say all right
let me find this study I swear to gosh
also I think men and women have
different definitions for what single
means yeah because the guys will just
say I'm single where the girls will say
I'm seeing someone or you know oh this
is in their 20s okay well I bet the
girls are just dating older it's
probably a mixable
it is just a research right so it's just
a survey I would imagine 30 percent of
U.S adults are neither married living
with a partner nor engaged in a
committed relationship nearly half of
all young adults are single 34 of women
in a whopping 63 percent of men like wow
how does that work how does it work if
there's roughly 50 percent women 50 men
how could 34 percent of women be single
and 63 percent of men be single it says
not surprisingly the decline of
relationships matches a strive of the
decline in sex the share of sexually
active Americans stands at a 30-year low
around 30 percent of young men reported
in 2019 that they had no sex in the past
year compared to about 20 percent of
young of young women only half of single
men are actively seeking relationships
or even casual dates according to Pew
that figure is declining what if like
the women thought they were in a
relationship and the guys are like right
yeah that's what we could say yeah that
you could say that or maybe the women
aren't being honest maybe they've gone
on a date with a guy and they decide
that's their boyfriend I don't know I
think the more shocking thing is just
that more in general are single less
people are having sex and are engaged in
meaningful yeah long-term relationships
see in the red pill space this is not
shocking at all because this is what
basically women we pick non-monogamy in
our 20s because you know if women are in
control of sex essentially and nowadays
sex comes before relationships now I
know you're gonna say well a good woman
or whatever
guys don't shoot the messenger all right
I've been doing these shows for a while
if I say this on a show most people will
say yeah okay there's maybe there's
little pockets in the country but we're
in 2020 those just called spade a spade
therefore women are in controlled
relationships so when women are in their
Peak we pick non-monogamy okay so like
and why do I say this well because even
if you could say Well they're in
relationships like they could pick
marriage but we don't and what I
realized is that
there's a growing proportion of young
sexless men and I don't think that's
really shocking to the guys to be honest
so women are basically sharing men in
their 20s and they pick someone to stay
within their 30s don't shoot the
messenger I'm just telling you what the
data says all right all right yep I
think that's you know there's there's
just an increasingly I feel like we're
becoming more atomized like you just
kind of can get lost in your world and
you get these pseudo communities popping
up like if I'm a board ape Yacht Club
member I could call you know I might say
those guys are my brothers but but are
they are they really like what is what
are what are these new community
internet communities doing right and
what are they not really replacing in
the real world because basically that's
what we've done we've replaced a lot of
physical things with online things and
sometimes that replacement works like I
can you know I can kind but sometimes it
doesn't like I can like FaceTime with my
mom and it's like kind of the same but
it's not it's not really it's a little
Annoying It's a little annoying right
and they're getting better at it but
it's like it's always kind of like this
like facsimile of the real thing and so
I think this replica AI is like it's
sort of this like it's trying to treat
loneliness in people yeah maybe you
could in that that's the nice way of
looking at it
um but it's kind it's pretty dystopian
man it is dystopian and one of the
things that I think uh accelerated it
was the lockdowns right so for yeah I
think so too the lockdowns it really
changed Society like I don't think
Society will ever be the same after the
lockdowns than from before like you see
more people working at home you see more
people it gets anti more anti-social I
mean it's come back a bit but I don't
know I don't think it'll ever actually
be the same especially people that have
a lot of anxiety there was people that
went a year plus without being in
contact with other people as other than
their immediate family members and so
then they seek More Time online they're
on online more and at the same time this
AI generated 3D image of a person is
communicating with you just that and
then and then the rise of like like
parasocial relationships you know that
people watch yeah yeah people watch so
much of online people they think they
know you and like yeah oh I've
experienced this it's like you meet
someone sometimes they're like oh how
was your lunch yesterday I saw that on
your store well I don't really put that
on my story but they would always ask me
about my coffee addiction they'd be like
how's your how's your coffee quitting
going and I'm like oh this is I did say
that online didn't I huh you don't but
but they feel like you're their friend
rather than them having like online
relate I was I was hanging out with a
few friends
um and you know they got approached by
some people these guys like felt like
they knew them like they're like oh
I love all your stuff what do you think
about they're asking about one of their
friends like what do you think about
when this guy did that and I'm thinking
like this guy doesn't know you
right it's but it's a strange thing
where that's our that's our new world oh
my gosh I would love to talk to Joe
Rogan about this stuff I feel like Joe
Rogan's like cued in but not completely
you know she's like why would that
happen well Joe
I think there's three reasons for for
the singleness epidemic with the men I
think women were either dating older or
or sharing guys or we think we're in
relationships when we're not yeah those
are my did I miss anything guys anything
no you're shaking their head all right
let me know what you guys think in the
comments um don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
and I'll talk to you next time